hey what is going on
youtube world
hey
uh first off let me know that you can
hear me okay and see me okay
give me a thumbs up
yes i can see you yes i can hear you
all that good jazz you never know you
never know when someone
you think you're talking live which
happened to me two weeks ago
and i'm seeing everyone's comments come
through and no one can hear me no one
can see me and uh
it was all great so
okay thank you luciano yes okay awesome
uh will yep okay awesome yeep yep that's
why i'd say yeep maybe
all good david all right awesome thank
you
still got my cough from last week
actually i've had this cough for four
weeks so good stuff um hey okay so um
how's everybody doing today how's
everyone doing
it's been a very uh
busy morning for me very busy morning
here in south florida but it's all good
how's everyone else doing
um today we're going to talk about third
party effects
and i'm going to show you two of my
favorites
two favorite third-party effects
one is free one is paid
but before i jump into showing those
effects to you i want to hear from you
and i want to know what your favorite
third party effect is
so please tell me in the chat box
what's your favorite third party effect
sometimes
i hear
the same effects over and over again
sometimes i'm really surprised by
effects that
maybe i haven't heard of before
um
nowadays there's so many effects that
are kind of being brought onto the
market
uh for after effects that um you never
know when something's gonna pop up
weekly right and kind of surprise you
with its power so
um
what's your favorite third-party effect
i know some people don't love to use
third-party effects and try to stay away
from them
but i'll tell you as a as a pro motion
designer
third party effects are key
to
really
speeding up your workflow
to
improving your workflow
helping with just
simple tasks you know just be it's all
about speed right and just beauty in
what you're creating so
um
yeah third party effects are awesome so
no one's got any good third-party
effects okay i'm surprised by this
i know there's a few people on here but
it's okay if you're if you're a little
bit shy today that's a-okay
turn that off
let's see okay we got red giant or
sapphire okay good ones
awesome
sapphire is always at my top so is red
giant actually
um
sabre is a cool free effect from video
co-pilot
uh i miss his old tutorials and wish he
was still doing them yeah i don't know
what's going on with andrew kramer
he's probably busy making movies right
deep glow
deep glow motion 2 element 3d modulation
ae viewer
ae viewer i'm not familiar with that one
see that's one i haven't heard of
or maybe i've heard of it i just haven't
looked into it
um
interesting
ryan what's going on ryan just
downloaded anubis and it's amazing okay
what is anubis
that sounds real if it's a game changer
i really want to know about it what is
anubis
uh david uses the saber for a lot of
work stuff sabre is an amazing
amazing plugin
that has so many different different
uses for it so i absolutely love saber
um
field house i got metal freeform pro
which is awesome i used to use metal
back in the day
yeah that's a powerful plugin
luciano red giant particular amazing
particle system
still my favorite particle system out
there
good good stuff
uh and good times hey cameron hope
paul's good all is very good thank you
uh guys in the middle of this i may have
to like turn my mic off for a second
i've got people outside mowing and
they're mowing at the absolute worst
time and they happen to come up when
they get close to this window there's
gonna be like there's a window right by
me they get super loud so uh bear with
me if that happens it only lasts about
15-20 seconds
um okay so if you don't know who i am
i'm assuming most you guys do but if you
don't i'll tell you really quickly my
name is cameron um i've been doing after
effects for 20 plus years
um started my first motion graphics
company in 2003 with my best friend
2005 after two years i went to work for
a regional company us then i started
moonlighting in 2006 for a variety of
companies became a remote freelancer in
2007
with my first big client being kyle
cooper uh who went on to create who had
created seven's title sequence which
he's a game changer in motion graphics
um and was a freelancer up until
2020 so
now i run motion science full time where
i train motion designers how to get
better at their craft
some of my clients have included 343
industries american express amstel nvcm
mtv pga
the list goes on and on that's a little
bit about me if you're not familiar with
me
let's jump in
and let's uh take a look at two of my
favorite plugins
flip the screen here
we're going to start with um my first
plug-in here which is a freebie
um and i'm just gonna bring in
i could have set this up ahead of time
um but i didn't
so let's go ahead and bring this up i
have a background layer here it's locked
i've got a
indian test pattern this is a pattern
that used to be
on the tv way back in the day
[Music]
and i like to use it for a lot of
different examples i'm going to invert
it
so it's
white on black
and then i'm going to
zoom in here
and just use my ellipse tool
hold down uh shift
i always forget here shift command
and kind of just draw this out just like
that
i'm going to duplicate this layer
and same so the layer on top is just a
circle the layer on the bottom we're
just going to invert it like that
i'm going to go to two views here let's
jump out of two views
and let's make this second view
yeah it's a top let's make our two
layers 3d
and
with the layer here that is just the
circle i'm just going to bring it
forward
um something like that right so it's
just sitting
in z space um further forward towards
the camera
go back to one view
here we go
and looks pretty much the same i'm gonna
go ahead and scale this guy down
so it kind of lines back up
maybe something like that so 81 percent
looks great
and then we're going to add a new camera
lay your new
camera
and we'll do 35 sure
and let's actually go ahead and scale
this guy down just a little bit more
based on that camera maybe even
you don't have to do this i just like to
have things kind of lined up like that
so we've got this
um you know it's kind of two and a half
d looking
thing here i'm just using my camera tool
here and just kind of moving around just
to show you that there's some depth
there so undo that
and now it's time for my plugin which is
animation composer
three at the time of this
live that is
what we're using
animation composer three
is free to to start with okay so it's
it's changed a lot over the years
now it comes with something called the
starter presets
which you should see here and
that's what comes free within the
plug-in plus there's some additional
tools there's an anchor point mover like
we see here if you click it it pops up
here
uh very handy you know a lot of people
make different anchor point movers this
one just happens to come inside this
script
we have a keyframe wing man which helps
to adjust
curves
and we've got a transition shifter
which gets a little bit more technical
but super easy to use if we want to kind
of shift transitions around and here
comes the
wind blowing guy
he's getting close hopefully it's not
too distracting
super distracting to me
um what's cool about this this this
plug-in this extension is
it's
when i first came across this this
script this plug-in this extension um i
was like oh that looks okay it looks
kind of cheesy you know like it can do
like some simple moves and things like
that
but when i started playing around with
it it's
i started to actually realize the power
of what this plug-in can do
and
one thing i really like to use it for is
like doing 3d moves right
here he comes
he's moving very slowly today
um i like to use it with 3d cameras
because it can create some really
interesting movement with 3d cameras
okay so just to show you and and i'm
going to caveat this by saying that
when you get into the 3d movements and
things like that these are upgraded
preset packs
um
[Music]
that can do some really cool stuff but
you can try with this basic starter
presets and it gives you a lot to work
with right so let's see what we got
transitions three layer
you can click on it and it shows you
like a preview here
and i don't want something totally crazy
but like something like this is kind of
nice and then if you open it up
you can see you can focus on like oh
here's on the bottom
or on the left right so maybe maybe the
left maybe you want to bring this this
object on screen right so all i have to
do it's important that you're at the
right place in your timeline for where
you want to apply this effect and you
can't apply it to a 3d camera but what
you can do and i'll show you if i try to
apply it here
it just gives me
in this error please select the layer so
i can do is i can actually go layer new
null object
i can make that null object 3d
and i can parent my camera to that null
object and now with the null object
selected
i can say animate in
right and boom
there it goes it gives us some some
things to work with here but if i
preview this now
let me move this out of the way
you can see
we've got a pretty interesting
you know move ends let me kind of
shorten the timeline here
now what you can do at this point is you
can start playing around with like the
angles
you can shift the transition
you can move the position the null
so
let's say we want to be
i don't know negative 60.
it's a little bit less of a move
maybe want it to be
negative 180 which this is going to be
too extreme i think
yeah it's quite extreme but you can see
how you can the power here of just
adjusting some parameters here and you
can adjust your movement and we made
this very quickly right now if i want to
adjust the timing all i have to do is
drag this slider i can make it now
really fast
see how fast it is it's like boom right
i can make it really slow
like that and just kind of
you know
much slower transition
now i can also um move some of these
windows out of the way here
i can go to remove right so let's say i
want to remove all this so let's go
ahead and remove that it gets rid of the
extra nulls it made boom they're gone
we're back to our original
uh layer our original animation which is
nothing
so those are some 3d transitions there's
also 2d transitions
um
you know because i'm working with the 3d
layer here i really want to see some of
the depth
i'm thinking
um sometimes you know 2d transitions
actually work really well with this kind
of stuff so let's try from
the bottom again let's apply it
and yeah see this one's give me an error
it's still doing the transition it's
just a little bit funky so let's go
ahead and remove this one
um let's see here
ease position i don't like to get them
too crazy let's actually move into
some motion presets 3d transitions
let's do
position
maybe overshoot
these are fun so you can do some really
interesting overshoots
right so maybe let's try this let's try
it
have it come in
and let's move this guy out of the way
yeah that's fun right so maybe it's too
fast
so i can drag that down
uh maybe i want see it's it's set to one
bounce let's try like i don't know some
do something crazy three
and you've got like three bounces here
and you can see how like again how
quickly i'm able to animate this
with just clicking a couple buttons
changing a couple numbers
and it's super super simple right
let's say
let's go ahead and remove
all these again
let's go back into
what's some other one how about position
what's this
one yeah these are a little crazy
because there's so many rotations
i can try it
a lot of times i try to stay away from
things that are
super complicated with the movement
you know that's actually okay
and again if we wanted to adjust like
if we were to go back here and kind of
look at where it's starting
see how it's quite a ways off camera
here so we could adjust maybe
you know maybe we have the angle start
here
or actually maybe we can you know do
something totally different maybe we
start it
um
something like that
yeah that's really cool
and then if you turn in you know turn on
motion blur
which is probably going to slow my
computer down here
but you add motion blur to things like
this
and the movements can get very um
realistic you know really quickly
so
this is something i love to use all the
time for 3d cameras
for those of you who have followed my
work for any period of time you know
that i use 3d cameras in pretty much
everything that i design and animate i
use a 3d camera for everything
it's a smarter way to work
so
uh this is just a an awesome tool to use
for creating movements um i could i'll
show you what else it does here let's do
a new composition
uh let's do that
and let's go up here and close some of
this um
it's got really cool like
basic backgrounds
right so we can see like different like
paint strokes here you can open them up
there's singles or combos
there's different shape elements
i think i've used pretty much every pack
that animation composer comes out with
and like i said for the longest time i
never bought any of these expansion
packs i used the basic tool the freebie
version
for so much of my animation work because
it's so
solid right there's so much there
these
i hear grunge textures i love texture
right so what's cool is like i can pick
like this fast texture here
and i can add it
to my composition
and there it is and it actually came in
at 4k
so if i wanted to scale this down let's
say 50
and let's play through this
you can see that there's different
parameters here again
for how you can control it like i can
actually adjust the duration
of this texture movement
to make it faster or slower i can
save palettes
color palettes i can tent very easily
so there we go there's
there's the texture
um if i wanted to like you know give it
like a
i don't know a pinkish purple look
there you go it's just it's super quick
i mean yes we can do this with tent but
it's nice that it's all kind of built
into this
um
plugin right it's really cool
so there's also
um if we go back here to browse
like i mean just there's some really
cool textures here right just
moving textures really cool to work with
i've used a lot of these there's fast
textures there's slow textures
like you see here
what else do we have here
so those are the textures we've also got
essential sound effects
maybe this is the one i've never used i
hardly ever use sound effects
for my work if it's going to be sound
heavy
i would probably pass that off to
somebody else to work on you know
someone else has a lot of expertise in
that in sound
um but
it's there
um there's also what else we got here
we've got text presets right
so
so many different types of text presets
that kind of take what's built into
after effects a step further or several
steps further
just some really fun and hopefully you
guys can see these windows okay these
previews
um i've used a lot of this stuff like
look at that that's just that's just fun
stuff right there right
so we have to what we have to do is
take our text tool
type here and put you know text
and
make sure that's enabled text is
selected actually let's make it quite a
bit um
let's make it quite a bit bigger
right
so we just got basic text here but if we
want to do something funky we can take a
preset apply it to that text and again
you get these parameters here that you
can play around with
and i mean you can just like i said you
can create some really awesome stuff
really quickly like let's turn the
intensity down to like 50.
um what's this plugin what it does is it
applies expressions to everything
um but it makes it so easy to change
those expressions wiggles per second
let's change it to like i don't know two
still pretty intense maybe take this
down to 20.
um
you know like this is just one of those
things i just love to play around with
the values and just see what happens
so
yeah lots of different presets
for text
um
gosh there's even like titles in lower
thirds
right like you can see here it's just
really simple examples here like if i
take
let's do this one
let's do
lower third
left one tier we're going to add that to
this composition
and
you can see i mean it's there we can
adjust the end point right we just slide
this end point in and i didn't show you
on the out point here but the out point
it's really easy to adjust as well
you can just adjust the slider
and um how you do it is you actually
just end
your
your layer there
that's where like let's say actually i
want to end it here
so super easy to use
absolutely love this
plugin
animation composer from mr horse
uh there's also shape transitions
shape elements
i don't know i don't get paid to talk
about this guy's stuff i've just used it
for years and i absolutely
love it
okay let's move on
to
this one i'm going to just save this
untitled project for some reason
okay so this is a project i built for
um a membership i have
but what i wanted to do was show you
some of the effects that i
have used for since 2007.
every
professional motion designer i know
uses
this suite of plugins and they're called
um sapphire from boris effect and
someone actually mentioned that in the
chat
um so
i've got an adjustment layer here just
kind of set over the top here and i was
just playing around this morning with
some different plug-ins or
effects from
boris fx and i kind of put these you
know up here because i just kind of
playing around but essentially what it
looks like is if you go to effect and
you go to sapphire
here we can see that there's a lot of
plugins here right
from adjust which is something i don't
use a ton of
blur and sharpen really powerful blurs
this is the sapphire builder so we can
build our own effects
sapphire composite
compositing tools
distort
lots of distortions lighting lots of
light that's probably my favorite suite
of plugins
render which creates
elements for you
stylize which is my second favorite
group of plugins and we've got time here
transitions here which are awesome
i think that's it so
there are so many i don't actually know
this is actually even an older version
of sapphire i think i'm two years back
i don't typically upgrade plugins very
often once i get a set of plugins that's
working really well i tend to stick with
it
so
i do need to upgrade my sapphire
i'm sure there's even more plug-ins now
included with boris effect sapphire
but what's also really great about
sapphire is the presets right so if you
go to like s glow this is one of my
favorite plugins of all time
[Music]
if you click on load preset here
it's going to load up a preset window
that you actually cannot see
because the way i have this set up let
me see if i can
change this really quickly here
there you should be able to see it now
um you can see just here with within
glow all these different presets uh for
glow right and some of them have
movement to them so if i click the play
button you can see some of that movement
in the noise dirty glow fire haze
glistening
goblins
soft
glow
fantasy
a lot of times i used to like to stick
with the default glow here
and then just play with some of the
parameters
so it's it can be a little bit um
i don't know at first when i first got
sapphire i saw some of these primers i
was like oh no like what do i even do
here how do i even
you know what do i play around with but
it's it's super easy to play around with
this glow plug-in all the sapphire
plug-ins are pretty simple to work with
um
you just have to kind of get in and just
play around right and
it's very intuitive right for what you
can do so in terms of glow there's a lot
of different glow plugins out there for
after effects
uh sapphire glow is still the best
in my opinion
uh so that's glow i've got another one
here for s shake sapphire shake that is
actually under effect uh sapphire
distort i believe yeah s shake right
here
and what this does is it creates
a camera shake right um
again if we turn on motion blur it's got
to look a little bit better
but if i hit the presets here
again i can hit um
the play button
and i can see
you know what's going on here so like
there's earthquake
uh beer goggles like whoa what's going
on
uh what shaken baby
you know it adds that motion blur to it
uh twitch channels just kind of
twitching the rgb channels
uh shake me gently
that's kind of nice just like a nice
little
handheld kind of movement so i'm gonna
load that in and then once i have that
preset i can
again tweak it within the plugins
parameters i find that sapphire
typically for the presets
they're really good
a lot of plugins
that you get for after effects
you can apply a preset you then have to
really tweak the parameters to make it
look good it's a lot of times the
presets are too over the top and you
have to really dial them back a lot of
times with sapphire that's not the case
i mean the presets are just awesome
right out of the box so
that's another good one there's also
grain
you know which we have built into after
effects but the grains within sapphire
are really awesome
glint this is like another lighting
effect
found under lighting
they can get some really interesting
looks
it probably would work better if i had a
color image here versus a black and
white
but you get the idea
we also have like jitter frames right so
this is a time effect so sapphire time
and where did it go
uh why am i not seeing it
jitter frames
right there
alphabetical there
so you can see what this is doing and
maybe i'm going to go down to half rows
here so i can play back a little bit
faster
it's just kind of like
it it's almost like this i think i think
of like a horror film or something you
know or like maybe like where we see
like things just moving in really
bizarre fashion
like that's what the pre the default of
jitter frames is again you can go in you
can you can play around with some of
these offsets and things like that
get some really interesting looks this
way
we've got flickr right so another one
under is that under
time yeah as flickr
excuse me this is a really nice
looking effect that just applies flickr
something i use in a lot of my work
load presets
again i'm going to click play up here so
i can see what's it looks like here
here's a flicker that's just colorized
right
campfire is really nice we got a horror
strobe
lightning
outlite phoenix
undulating fear
zotrope
but the default is really nice
i've also got let's see here
what else oh trails right
under time so i wanted to show you guys
some of these time effects because
people a lot of times are like what can
you do with a time effect
um but um
trails is really trippy right so look at
it right out of the box look what it's
doing there
again
you know it's like a flashback scene or
it's
um
you're trying to create like a retro
looking animation or something like that
trails is awesome for that kind of stuff
you've got a logo flying through the
across the screen and you see these
trails kind of coming behind it
really really interesting looks
we've got
stylize stylize like i said is my second
favorite area to go into film effect
that just gives your your
composition like that film look right
that contrast that
grain all that film damage
is another one i absolutely love
i've always loved like the old film
damage looks um so it you know creates
some really interesting dust
scratches it's got that flicker built
into it some of these plug-ins it brings
up a great point um some of these
plug-ins are using multiple plug-ins
within sapphire
layered together to give you the effect
so like this one's using
flicker
built into it it's probably using even
like a a noise generator to create the
the dust
the scratches
all that good stuff
lots of great presets in here
again with the newer version of sapphire
you'll probably even get more
looks than just this one
you can see
you know just some really nice
some of them are over the top right a
little bit too much for me
some of them don't move
in the playback and that's okay like a
lot of times i just
if i kind of like how it's looking i'll
just click load and then bring it into
my composition preview and see how it
looks
grind house this is a good one
super 8
you know pretty heavy on the
scratch or the hair there
kitchen sink everything's just kind of
brought into it
classic film noir
again if i load it up you can see it's
got a really nice contrast to it really
nice grain to it i can add additional
details like scratches by coming over
here right there's a slider or i can put
in a number here so let's say i want
heavy on the scratches there's some
heavy scratching there
i can adjust the vignetting the flicker
amount
uh let's take it up to like 0.4
right so now you can see it's a bigger
amount of flicker
defocus details right defocus is set to
zero if i take it up to once but yeah
it's gonna get crazy right it's just
like the camera is constantly
losing focus
uh two intense
even maybe even like a point one or
something a lot of times you want like
very low values right in these effects
but uh really cool one
and then also under let's go back to
sapphire distort
warp chroma so you know chromatic
aberration is
it's been popular for years it's still
around it kind of just gives your work
kind of like that extra finish at the
end
to make it look a little bit more
realistic a lot of times
motion designers can overdo it
or
really just really push it too far
it looks really cheesy
this is obviously
way over the top but i like to load
presets here
and then my favorite is the second one
here
uh chromatic
aberrations what they call it
and you can but there's also some other
really nice ones here like moderate warp
um for like some dream sequences things
like that subtle warp
but chromatic aberration
loaded in there
and i mean you can see it already looks
really nice
i like to take my from z distance from
0.97 to
0.985
or even 0.99 i want it to be very very
subtle
but again this is a great way to get
chromatic aberration so
it's one of those finish effects
finishing effects that i always
typically always put on my work at the
end
to really just kind of bring it to that
next level
and it kind of just brings back it
removes some of that digital feeling
and
brings back some of that analog feel so
those are the ones i kind of pulled out
ahead of time um
was it s builder this is the effect that
you can actually use to
build your own effects
very very powerful i've had buddies that
have built their own effects through
here i've never personally done it
but under s builder there's also like
additional presets for different um
effects right
there's some really really cool stuff in
here um some film looks some just i mean
everything it's the whole kitchen sink
here within the builder
uh to work with
so um what else do i wanna show you
really quickly here
um i mean like this is just one of those
plugins it's so much fun just to dive in
and just play around with all of them
right
every feature film
that you're seeing is has pretty much
has sapphire
used in some capacity um a lot of times
i guess i would think of these more as
on the
on the old school style of motion design
which is kind of what i do
uh where it's a combination of footage
with graphics it's not just 2d graphic
based right vector based
um these type of effects aren't going to
work very well with that stuff
but i mean
there's so much you can do here i mean
like warp fish look at that
so so cool um
let's see what the presets are here oh
yeah so
you know i mean like look at that it's
just craziness
fish island that's really cool
it's kind of the opposite effect right
it's pushing it back
that's
pretty neat
so much cool stuff under lighting like i
said with boca lights and
glow distortions and lens flares and
light leaks and
i mean i could spend
all day showing you sapphire's plugins
and
just
you know creating new stuff it's so much
fun so
that's what uh that's what i recommend
for
some of my favorite plugins for um
third-party plugins
let me switch back over here
i can't see
there we go
yeah so if you guys have any questions
about um the plugins i just showed you
i'd be happy to answer them for you
um
let's see here ryan said
pull this back up
battle axes do plugin for quick exports
from ae awesome huh
interesting so it's quick exports from
after effects
um i guess all i ever use is you know
media encoder
um that's just kind of my go-to now it's
funny because for years i stayed away
from media encoder
and just rendered straight out after
effects and then they really beefed up
media encoder to do so many different
things now
it's kind of my go-to
okay so it's uh good to know matt i've
had people tell me before they can hear
this guy actually didn't get too close
right like sometimes he's within five
feet of me
and uh maybe he's taking it easy today
universal audio is a lifesaver for me i
i'm not familiar with that one either
you have to tell me thrl what is
universal audio
what is that
rare parrot not familiar with that one
either hey kermit what's going on
element 3d you know with element 3d
i do have it um i think i've owned it
for
many many many years and i have used it
one time
in my entire freelancing career i used
it for some typography
that i had to extrude very quickly
and kind of do like a logo animation
with it and it worked for that but uh
for me it's not a plugin that i found a
lot of use for
um
i have a
friend who uses it extensively and
creates amazing stuff
so
um
check out ae suites very cool okay oh
you know i think i have heard of ae
suites yeah
that's awesome i'll check it out
okay my friends well um
that's all i got for you guys today um i
hope you learned something new out of
this
per usual um just trying to give you a
lot of value and
you know hopefully you learned something
from what i teach you
um but i do plan on being back here uh
next tuesday and um i can't remember
what the topic's gonna be
actually i'll look it up really quickly
here
actually it's not pulling up
um i am going to do another uh video in
the coming weeks about my favorite
plugins within after effects that are
built into it
i think that would be very powerful as
well
oh yes so next week we're going to talk
about things you didn't know after
effects could do so
there's a lot of things out there after
effects can do that a lot of people
aren't familiar with so that's we're
going to talk about next week
friends thank you so much for showing up
today and listening to what i have to
say
everyone take care and uh as always keep
on creating and
getting better at what you do have a
good one